[Music]
you like to tweet about how much you
love Chris Bosh yes of the Miami Heat
and then you finally got to meet him I
understand is that right I did get to
meet him in person however he does not
know that okay
help me with that because you're a big
fan you get to meet him and he's unaware
that you met you it's a long story but
the short version is this he did a cameo
on Parks and Rec this year and I found
out no one had told me even though I
tweet about him like seven times a day
no one happened to tell me that he was
coming so I waited for him in the hair
and makeup trailer and I was gonna be
like hey I am obsessed with you how are
you and and he was late or something and
I was just kind of fidgety and nervous
so I was like well I know what I'll do
I'll do a hilarious bit where I dress up
like the hair person and I pretend to be
the hair person but he'll know it's me
because I'm me right he's on the show
and your show and he'll get ya everyone
knows who I am
oh he'll just know and so I took the
hair person in Helena's sweater and her
glasses and I created you know a
10-second I did a ten-second creation of
a character which I'm sure you do a lot
and put a lot of thought and time into
my characters thank you
there's my pirate and then go all right
and then he came in and I was like doing
my character but thinking that
immediately he'd be like oh it's Aubrey
Plaza and he did not recognize me so I
kept playing the character to the point
where I did his hair he did not know
that I wasn't me he just thought I was a
crazy hair person did you ever like take
off your glasses and I took my glasses
off at the end and and took a picture
with him but like he's still like just
thought I was a crazy person oh he
didn't end up recognized me no he didn't
recognize me and I I it went on for so
long that at one point in my head I was
like this is the the saddest moment of
my life
break character and say it's me because
it was obviously me so he obviously
doesn't know who I am the lesson I
learned was sad no one knows who I am so
and then I went home that night after he
left and he was very nice and cool and I
went home and I tweeted hey Chris Bosh
that was me that did your hair and no
response I think we have the picture
here of you with Chris Bosh and he has
no idea wow that's well that he's gonna
know now this is gonna get back oh sure
I've been waiting for a long time yeah
his hair looks great his hair you did a
great job on this there
I don't know what you did I just rubbed
it